[Music]
gentlemen there is a war raging right
now with the Magisterium between those
trying to keep us in ignorance and those
willing to fight for truth and freedom
who will stand with me it's kind of
heresy is highest priority to the
Magisterium I need to know where he's
going and what he intends to achieve
can't stake Louvre is no place for a
child
no the master is asked if I can find a
place for you and I want you as my
assist you're an explorer too just like
my uncle I can teach you to wield power
you must let me ride you we believe
there is an organization that a stealing
children and taking north
sometimes
children can just disappear I promise to
do everything I could to protect you
from harm
it's an LED orbit it is illegal unless
approved by the Magisterium tells you
the truth
she has to make a journey one which I'm
afraid includes a great betrayal
it's trying to relieve me of something
I suspect it's trying to warn you of
everything
he scores me
I can fly any questions should be asking
you that we are not Magisterium madam
awesome I would ask where I could obtain
services and armored bear burek Bernsen
as people need our help Yorick
it's time I know
[Music]
[Music]